most of us have been stuck inside and if
you're like me you've been wearing the
same clothes just about
every day for the last year have you
been doing that too yeah yeah
we're all doing it we're all been just
wearing the same
casual sloppy clothes day in and day out
for the last year
but with things starting to open up now
okay because
people are getting their shots i think
that time may be drawing to a close
luckily our new sponsor
has he covered the world is starting to
reopen
and after wearing the same pants and top
for the last 12 months
it's time to think about a second outfit
at second outfitters we have the kind of
clothes you wore
before the pandemic and you can re-learn
how to wear those clothes at one of our
special seminars
including how to tie a tie what an iron
is and what it does and how to walk in
shoes where for some reason
the heel is several inches above the toe
second outfitters because clothes can do
more than just hide your ass from your
kids
clothes can do more than just hide your
ass from your kids
well let's face it that was a fake shut
up plenty
god i can't work like this it's terrible
the guy who runs this theater is this
irishman named flanagan and all he does
is
ah it puts me in mind of a story about
10 years ago
i was walking down the lane you can't
get any work done
unbelievable i asked soon if i should
order you something and she said i'm
fine
yes that makes sense flanny that makes
sense